so the question is what is the perfect
diet okay what what would you think
would be the most perfect diet in the
world because there's a millions of them
and if you start doing Google searches
you're going to be very very very
confused so what I want to do to answer
that question is to give you a principle
that you should eat for nutrients
because the healthiest most perfect diet
in the world would satisfy all of the
nutrient requirements I'm not talking
about eating some food and taking some
synthetic vitamins with it or having a
food that has enriched with synthetic
vitamins that's not perfect I'm talking
about a diet that would satisfy all the
nutrients that you need a diet that
would be that would create the most
health and have the properties in those
foods that would enhance and prevent the
most health problems like there are
foods out there that prevent cancer
there are foods out there that will
prevent macular degeneration your vision
that will help protect you down the road
in bulletproof your health preventively
and then the most perfect diet would be
those foods that would contain the most
that are most natural okay so of course
you have the difference between
wild-caught and farm raised fish which
should be like like hormone pellets and
things like that or free-range vs. farm
like in this in this barn where they
have three thousand chickens and one
tiny little cage or you have organic
versus regular hormone fed animals like
that type of thing or pesticides sprayed
on the foods so the most perfect diet
obviously wouldn't include those and it
would include GMO foods genetically
modified foods so you want to look at
the food the foods that would satisfy
the majority of the deficiencies now it
makes no sense to take vitamins unless
your food you're eating is corrected so
what I'm trying to do is in trying to
tell you this you want to look at food
from a different angle not necessarily
what you feel like eating this all the
time but what during a given day
how am I gonna get the nutrition okay
but how do you know that that's kind of
it's hard to find that so what I did is
I created some software I took me over
two years and I personally invested of
my own money about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to build this software
so I hope you appreciate it because it's
a free software for anyone and all it
does is it analyzes what you eat in a
given day and it compares it with all
the nutrients that you should be having
for your age for your sex male or female
and it will then tell you what you're
deficient in okay and then not only that
it'll tell you what foods to eat more of
and in the amounts that you need to eat
them why is that viable because very few
people are getting enough nutrition from
the diet that they're eating right now
and so what we want to do is know are we
deficient well before we become
deficient so this is more of like
preventative stuff why would you wait
until you're deficient in a nutrient to
develop a problem and then try to fix it
with a vitamin when you can actively eat
the nutrition right over here so you
never end up like that so it's it's very
very very simple and very logical but to
do that you really need to evaluate what
you do eat because let's just take one
mineral potassium potassium is needed in
the amounts of 4700 milligrams per day
now you might say why eat a banana
really well that's about 400 milligrams
you need for you're not going to eat 12
bananas a day so what you can do is you
can find out what foods have the highest
potassium not just bananas and then eat
more of those if you're deficient and
then it will evaluate some of the trace
minerals that you need to like iodine
and selenium
all these trace minerals that are not in
our soils in the US they're probably in
Hawaii because the volcanic ash laid out
the trace minerals and and Italy
probably or Europe or Russia or even
Africa but not in America because we
don't put these trace minerals back into
the soil
so you want to start focusing on foods
that have the most nutrition but what I
did is it creates
we're to make it easy for you to figure
that out okay so what I want you to do
is to go down here click the link below
fill out one day of food and it will do
the rest it will evaluate all your
information compare it to what what you
should be getting nutrition wise it'll
graph it for you and then it'll tell you
what foods to put more attention on over
time and I would recommend to take this
quiz maybe once a month to get an idea
if you're how far how close or how far
away you are from the ideal perfect diet
so take the quiz and apply the
information